lundi soir dans avignon au la mitis
matane matapédia et militants du bloc
sont réunis pour célébrer la victoire de
leur candidate christine michaud tout le
monde est motivé par ceux à qui ça
ravive un peu la flamme la remontée
bloquiste donne des ailes aux militants
souverainistes qui ont connu leur lot de
déboires ces dernières années à la fois
sur la scène fédérale
la scène québécoise on se disait bon on
a assez fertile mais là quand les plus
jeunes sont arrivés on s'est senti
interpellé des non choix de doute
ici les organisations bloquistes et
péquistes sont bien et briquet la
nouvelle députée du bloc était jusqu'ici
attaché au cabinet du chef parlementaire
du parti québécois pascal bérubé et
c'est la machine électorale du député
péquiste qui a servi à faire élire
la candidate bloquiste qui étaient les
organisateurs de tous ses gains là
partout au québec
bath et des militants du parti québécois
et du bloc québécois qui sont soit les
mêmes essentiellement dont qui ont
dirigé les campagnes ont fait des
téléphones qui ont animé les milieux
tous espèrent que la remontée bloquiste
pave la voie à la renaissance du parti
québécois
j'ai vraiment essayé un regain de
nationalisme au québec et nationalisme
au niveau du bloc mais je pense que ça
peut avoir une inflation depuis que je
l'espère en tout cas
mais l'histoire invite à la prudence si
le bloc québécois avait fait campagne
uniquement sur la question de
souveraineté et qui avait obtenu le
score qu'il a obtenu je serais d'accord
avec pour dire que les espoirs du parti
québécois sont frottés en 2011 le bloc
encaissait la pire défaite de son
histoire
ce qui n'a pas empêché le parti
québécois de prendre le pouvoir l'année
suivante
vous n'avez pas des masses des lecteurs
toujours fidèle toujours partisan qui
vont toujours voté dans du même côté au
provincial qu'au fédéral soit je pense
que ça va à l'encontre de la tendance
dominante dans l'évolution du
comportement électoral où c'est un peu
chacun pour soi et on est un peu devenus
des consommateurs surtout que le bloc
québécois a axé sa campagne sur les
revendications nationalistes de la cac
une comparaison des résultats de
l'élection de lundi à celle des
élections provinciales de l'an passé
illustre d'ailleurs à quel point les
gains du bloc se sont faits en
territoire caquistes je veux pas un lien
direct avec l'avenir du parti québécois
saut sur le fait que parti co foyer et
un jeune allemand devient une force
politique et ça s'est inspiré pour le
parti québécois
[Musique]
même si l'effet n'est pas direct
l'arrivée de 32 député souverainiste à
ottawa semble à tout le moins
ragaillardir les militants péquistes et
aidera sans doute le parti à mieux se
financer et se reconstruit ici vous la
vallée radio-canada a beaucoup